I think a lot of people assume
that being interested in beauty and fashion is, like,
a vein pursuit,
but in reality,
it has a lot more to do with energy
and your alignment with the universe than you think.
I'm sure you've heard the phrase look good,
feel good, but I think it's more than that,
because when you feel confident,
and that doesn't mean you have to feel confident
in something that somebody else would feel confident in.
But if you are dressed in a way that aligns how you feel on the inside
with how you present on the outside,
it's almost as as if you're
public and private
identities are working together to maximize your power.
And people can really sense that.
You know, when you look at your favorite creators
who have gone on a style journey
or a style evolution,
the energy that they put out into the universe,
the things that come their way,
the people and connections they meet become maximized.
And it almost has nothing to do
with the type of clothes they're wearing
or the style that they are embodying,
and so much more to do with the energy shift
that happens when they are dressing for their true selves.
Which is why I take a tiny bit of issue with trend following,
because if the fashion that you're wearing doesn't align with, like,
your inner self,
it can sometimes feel like a costume.
Like, are you performing the role Of a fashionable person?
Or are you dressing in a way that makes your soul light up?
Which is why I'm not anti trend.
I'm simply anti only dressing trendy,
because I think it doesn't allow you the opportunity
to align your fashion with your inner self,
which is why you see so many celebrities
who kind of stick to a signature style.
Jennifer Aniston is a fabulous example of this.
She embodies this, like,
relaxed California cool girl aesthetic,
and she seems like that person.
It's a good fit.
So as much as a style journey can be about simply outward aesthetics,
it's also about harmonizing your inner self.
So in some ways,
finding your personal style
may turn out to be one of the least shallow things you do,
because it is kind of that deep.